let's get to the most I was a pressing
matter but it's really not in the world
of you know civil unrest pandemics and
economic catastrophes but it is a
pressing matter and it is something
people have a lot of interest in and it
is something that everybody's kind of
talking about this week and it does in
fact LA and it is serious and it is
something that I want to talk about and
it's something I've talked about before
on this show and that it is that ocean
Prime is back open the steakhouse ocean
prime which is a lot of good seafood and
it's in Beverly Hills and I think that
it's back open on the patio now they do
you have inside dining but they're
encouraging people to go on the patio
and I think that's important it's
important that people go back out on the
patio and be careful but also enjoy
yourself
oh sure prime is also of course offering
curbside to go that's I'm kidding that's
a joke that's a joke of course story I'm
talking about is a lot of people are
trying to recall Gavin Newsom the
governor of California and people said
to me where are you on this and you know
he's you know he's about decent looking
and he's done it fair you know whatever
he's a little drunk on his own power but
who is it you know I was watching this
there's a great this is show on Netflix
called you have you seen this why are
you laughing have you seen this show on
Netflix yeah yeah called you it's the
guy from Gossip Girl Penn Badgley Bagley
I don't know how to say his name and and
he plays a serial killer and the first
episode is in Brooklyn the first season
is in Brooklyn and the second season is
in Los Angeles California and I was
watching this show
and this show is very fun to watch I
mean it is you get its I mean it's not
fun to live I imagine but it is fun to
watch I mean it is a very watchable show
it's a very watchable show I'm you know
was in it you know who's in the show
comedian she knows in the show is it
Chris D'Elia
no it's comedians act Jerry can you
google Zak shine look a sec cherry Chris
is in it as well Google Zak this is the
big guy
comedians actuary you know say he's a
big boy but he's a fun man chris is in
it as well what does Chris play in the
show a pedophile well he plays a
comedian who is into an underage girl
here's the thing folks he plays a
character named Henderson I've spoken to
Chris Lee about three times in my life
they've all been in a Comedy Store and
he's been very pleasant to me now that
is not a defense and that it's not me
trying to qualify anything I'm gonna say
here but I will say that Chris has been
very kind to me and he's said that I'm
very funny and that does count a little
bit it does not not it doesn't excuse
what is shaping up to be some very
disturbing allegations but he's always
been very nice to me chris is one of
those guys who took a real famous
comedian like when you look at his
Instagram it's like Machine Gun Kelly
would comment he did the thing with
Eminem
he's like the LA comic right he's like
Bieber's favorite comic right like
Bieber will go to the store right yes
yeah it's everything in comedy that like
I am I am not that like I am not like
the guy that's cool who has a fan base
that's cool you know what I mean
like the last person to retweet
something I did
was really big was candy silence so
let's just you know I'm like not a cool
comic and Chris is a cool comic no not
that that has done uncool things but I
mean like but he's very sweet to me
listen everybody knew the dude got laid
we just knew he got laid because his fan
base was women women would attack him in
the whole of the comedy store they would
run up to him I'm not saying I'm not
saying that they are but I'm saying from
my own eyes I would see like women go up
to him and like he was that like women
don't come up to me after the set and go
[Music]
thank God I saw you in force with my
girlfriend you're so high your tits are
so hot I say it in fourths you're so hot
that doesn't really hot like that's not
the type of comic I am sadly it would be
nice if I was like you know pulling up
in a hot car yeah I usually get out of
an uber it's usually a frustrated asian
man so I don't know I don't know if the
minivan Doors automatic and why even
ever hit but that's so listen if you're
just [ __ ] a lot of chicks that are of
age and they're mad at you it's it's on
them right I mean listen women have
agency women are smart women can make
choices now if those women are underage
that's a serious problem it's a legal
problem it's a moral problem it's an
ethical problem
and I imagine if more of that comes out
it's gonna be dealt with in a court
which is where you know unfortunately
you know should be dealt with because
that is criminal activity um if you're
19 and you're mad because you know you
know the guy whose hotel room you want
to a tree I'm turned out not to be a
gentleman this is a learning experience
for all involved but if you're underage
and your message that is [ __ ] not
right and that'll be dealt with in a
court of law
I would imagine or you know it's also
dealt with in the court of public
opinion where people go somebody who's
doing that he's just not somebody that
people want to do business with anymore
or establish a friendship with you know
I you know I hope that stuff isn't true
but you know I when I was on keto I
hoped that that would work do you see
what I mean
you know Obama used to say hope is a
powerful thing not really it's not that
powerful facts gravity immutable laws
those things occasionally fly in the
face of hope so I hope that did that is
there is no truth to the allegations
that he was messaging underage girls now
it does seem that sadly my hope is not
going to stand up against and by the way
I hope that for everyone involved I hope
it for the girls opened for him I hope
that like that's not going on am I gonna
get a better spot at the store because
he won't be there let's be honest yes
I'm not I'm not gonna lie I mean we get
over it might not be you be there but
I'm kidding we're kids a comedy show
we're doing a comedy podcast and I wish
everyone well here's a
it's a bad situation for a lot of people
that knew him that are very disappointed
and disgusted and you know there's a lot
of [ __ ] I bet that guy he sadly has a
lot of demons a lot of things that he's
fighting and it's a whole thing's bad
whole thing is no good naked but
everything I'm involved in is destroyed
I got into subprime mortgages they would
we you know we had a recession Adam
McKay was producing a show of mine and
then he dissolved his company with Will
Ferrell Gary Sanchez Anthony Bourdain's
company was producing my travelogue with
Comedy Central and he hung himself in a
room several days later my agent who
signed me in 2016 is no longer working
at the agency that signed me I mean I
tend to get into the party as the party
is break it up I tend to arrive at the
party as the cop cars are being seen
through the window and this is maybe
literally now but that's when I get to
the party and that's unfortunate so if I
walk in I mean it's countdown till
something's gonna go down and it's not
gonna be good so again I feel for the
firt for the victims of this like the
women that were messaged and were made
to feel uncomfortable that were underage
that is illegal and that is wrong I do
not feel for the comedians who are
complaining that they don't get better
spots I I think it's a little disgusting
to try to weave your own personal
narrative into this and your own gripes
and your problems Chris kill whether you
like his comedy not Chris killed
he killed harder at the store than
anyone I've ever seen I mean he earned
his spots at The Comedy Store he had
theaters of thousands of people coming
to see him I mean whether you liked his
comedy or not it doesn't matter people
did and they came to see him and he made
money so the comics that are out there
now and they did this with Louie they
did this with everybody
come out DuckDuckGo dude sucks he's dark
there's not even good at comedy like me
stuck gonna calm me like Miss alright
man get online create your own [ __ ] and
you know it's [ __ ] stop whining you
know but I mean this is Thursday night
early Friday morning more may come out
more is may come out um I would imagine
that this rocks things a little bit here
in this town um I've only been here a
year seems like it may be time to start
thinking about pizza again and the
Hudson River if we could get de Blasio
out of there get the cove it out in the
de Blasio up maybe I'll Wallace back
I think Rogen's teasing that he's moving
to another state Chris seems unfocused
at the moment cuz he'd be the next
biggest act so I don't know what's gonna
happen out here but you know see me
here's me there he goes there he goes
see him just one taco one last taco yeah
you know I feel bad for you know the
women that were affected you know I mean
this is shitty and I don't know facts
this is the other thing I've not done a
deep dive on the facts doesn't mean I'm
doubting people and not believing them
I'm saying I have not personally looked
into this at all have you looked at any
of the facts really I mean facts I mean
I guess anything could be photoshopped
right I mean these are just screenshots
I mean the idea that all these people
are coming together and photoshopping a
bunch of things seems to be do you think
it's the Russians do you think it's a
rush
it's Russian Bob do you think it's these
two Chinese it would be and I'm not
saying that he should do this but it
would be beyond funny if he came out and
said this was Russia yeah like if he
came out and he said first they install
Donald drop the puppet
then they manufacture a bunch of
screenshots and take me down goddamn
them the Russians Putin [ __ ] you Putin I
don't want to laugh folks I don't want
to laugh because people are getting it
angry with me for laughing they're gonna
go to sue I know it's a serious
situation but I deal with serious
situations with humor it's you know I
just have to let but and you know but
it's it's you know wherever it goes it
goes I don't know what to tell you you
know uh you know probably was not Russia
I don't know or China yeah I imagine it
wasn't China I mean it seems legit it
it's it's unfortunate that this is
happening you know there's so much good
news in the country by the way this is
like the entertainment news right the
good news is so bad now they're like
this is entertainment news you know
they're like any in the entertainment
corner this is the fluff right this is
the light-hearted fluff news that you
get if he was doing that is so weird to
take that role on that show you on
Netflix it's very strange to take that
role he imagined like taking that role
if you were doing that like it as if to
say how could I be doing this if I did
take this role yeah you imagine that you
have the script and you're like Jesus
Jesus this is good but that's you know
that's kind of what we're gonna say
about that there's no no new facts about
it yet um and you know we're gonna
withhold I'm not the judge in the jury
but I am someone in the courtroom
sitting around eating potato chips who's
gonna talk [ __ ] after the trial so
that's what I'm doing I don't know the
facts I haven't done a deep dive the
facts are disturbing that are coming out
you know um and that's where I'll leave
it you know a lot a lot bigger people
are gonna have something to say about
this I'm sure people that knew him well
celebs and friends and whatever you know
I don't know it's like what do you think
the implications are about this why
don't you make a statement why do I make
god [ __ ] stay I have to make a state
why don't you make a statement
where's Jamie Vernon on this where's all
the other producers you guys [ __ ] sit
and listen to everything everybody says
and then you don't have to have a
goddamn stay we all got to come out with
statements you're in the [ __ ] room
for everything that we all say and
nobody says anything huh so you want me
to have a take on it well what's your
statement what's your take my take
that it's bad to be a pedophile that's
it but he's not a pedophile our FIBA
file it's bad to be at a FIBA file get
the word up please
now I'm not gonna correct people on
Twitter it seems like an odd Hill to die
on I think Neil I think Neal Brennan was
doing it
the Oh Brendan was like in the middle of
the night be like it's a Hiba file I
just woke up I looked at my phone oh my
god what's this guy doing Neil put your
phone down the [ __ ] are you doing he
searched actually he before Wow hey Neil
Hiba thelia is a primary sexual interest
in mid to late adolescence generally
ages 15 and 19 it's a number it is one
of a number of sexual preference across
age groups subsumed under the technical
term Crona feel yeah I don't know that
means what is a Hiba file is that
somebody likes Jews Akiba file it's the
thing what's a Hiva file see somebody
who likes Jews somebody who's attracted
to men in large hats with beards who own
who own projects in Brooklyn people I'm
attracted to men with beards who own
low-income housing in Williamsburg what
are you or you're a Hiba file I don't
know okay well listen there you have it
folks I mean that's Ben's [ __ ]
statement you know nice and simple is it
all over the news
it's all over the news right yeah I mean
when you type in his name to Twitter it
seems like there's still like 20 tweets
a minute I'd say and there's still news
articles about it so it's up there but
you know he was trending at the same
time that world war 3 was trending so
you know right there's just so much
going on there's a lot going on here I
go I grab the debride oh there he goes
Delta is that you going up the plane yes
as I leave Los Angeles gets bombed by
China
I just wave I land in New York I just
put a pizza I just take a bite of pizza
and I'm like it's New York you know what
are you gonna do well all right
everybody we're gonna continue to record
the rest of the episode tomorrow I just
I felt like I should address this
tonight and you know maybe tomorrow
everything I said will be well if they
start finding bodies you know if they
find like 10 bodies well we just want to
put this out yeah we will if they find
10 bodies I'm sitting there like
tomorrow as to come in like this I'm
like aah
what if the Andrew Santino kills his
wife tonight I gotta come in and I gotta
be like ah Tony Hinchcliffe gets drunk
he kills a family of four on the 405 I'm
like you know uh Whitney coming
bludgeons our dog to death I'm like you
know I have to make a four statements to
make four statements today